a tv series that will be a direct sequel
to the original classic 1968 planet of
the apes
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
[Music]
so the original 1968 planet of the apes
movie did actually have a sequel all
planned out pierre boulet who wrote the
original also wrote a sequel
planet of the men
yuri singer and amy perenae god i hope
i'm saying these names right
have actually bought the rights to that
novel and plan to turn it into a tv
series
we'd actually basically know what the
plot is for that tv series and that is
pretty poetic george taylor charlton
heston's character and nova move on from
the statue of liberty you maniacs
and go into the forbidden zone where
they find a group of humans that are not
subjugated by the apes
charlt heston's character taylor goes on
to become their kind of leader and helps
them start building up a resistance
that resistance actually eventually
overthrows the ape city along the way
the apes try to have a counter attack
and try to wipe out this resistance but
they completely underestimate the rage
and the resourcefulness of the humans
and the attack goes completely sideways
eventually though the humans actually
turn on taylor's character who has by
now had a childhood nova they decide
that he is too sympathetic towards the
apes as he is still friends with a
couple of them including cornelius etc
taylor's character believes that not all
apes are bad
so the humans turn on him and kill him
they then destroy the apes culture and
civilization and take over
the apes revert back to a more primitive
state
now i've got to say i don't think the
script for this original would have
worked as a movie but as a tv series
something that they can flesh out over
two three four series could be really
really interesting and i think there's
an opportunity here to have lots of
little metaphors about the way humanity
and
nature coexist with each other
there are some stories out there that
this is going to turn into a massive
legal battle but not necessarily i got a
little bit of advice from a friend who
works in this sort of field and she has
told me there is actually no reason why
this tv series can't be produced
now at the moment planet of the apes is
owned by fox which is owned by disney
so
there might be some gray areas here but
not necessarily and to be honest it's
more likely that they'll just come up
with some sort of agreement because
having a long drawn out court battle
isn't really necessary and doesn't
really do anybody any favors it's a
little bit like sony and marvel over
spider-man where
they own elements of the spider-man
character but maybe not others so having
a long drawn out legal battle really
serves no one and just costs everyone
money
so i don't think there will be a massive
legal battle over this tv series
also this doesn't sort of trample on the
kind of movies that we've had the 2001
remake and then the more recent rise of
the planet of the apes and war of the
planet the apes it doesn't necessarily
need to trample on those as canon
as the planet of the apes movie actually
follows rise of the planet apes and war
of the planet apes
so does this movie so to be honest it's
a continuation of a story we've already
had it's not going to peel over cannon
or change anything necessarily it's just
the next bit and for once this isn't a
reboot or a hard reboot it's a new
project with actually an original story
so you know
i'm quite looking forward to this i
think this is something that could be
pretty good
but what do you think please get in the
comments tell me are you bothered by
this do you think this is a tv show that
you'd like to see and where do you think
it'll end up i'm thinking hbo max but
we'll see
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out you
can also become a fully fledged side
tracker and join us on the channel hit
that join button
and as always please guys stay safe i'll
see you next time
you